I'm doing to your one word book events
including one today in LA what's up
believe nation so I got asked a lot from
people if I was doing a book tour doing
any events around the book how they
could meet me get some signed copies and
I thought I don't know if I want to do
with my publisher said not to do it and
so what i thought was listen I'm
traveling to LA I'm actually here not
right now but would you guys to watch
this video I'm here in LA and I thought
let's do one in LA let's do one in
Toronto and then we'll see how it goes
so the LA one I have a meeting in
Beverly Hills that ends at three o'clock
no let's start at three o'clock pacific
and so I thought hey let's do a five
o'clock specific meet up in Beverly
Hills or those of you who want to get
your book signed want to talk about the
book want to do itself you want to meet
want to chat I love to meet you and hang
out so that one is happening today you
don't have a lot of time 5pm specific
today the address is peet's coffee 258
south beverly drive beverly hills
california 9021 to hopefully you are in
LA or in the LA area i will see you
there at five o'clock today the second
one is i'm launching a series of your
one word workshops in toronto so if
you're in the Toronto area we're doing
our first one on april third I'm going
to be there I'm actually having my
instructor run it for me so lily is one
of my dance instructors at traumas and
salsa who's embraced her one word and
she's gonna be teaching a two-hour
workshop on april eighth from one to
three pm eastern going through the core
concepts in the book it's forty dollars
to join if you do you get a free copy of
the book which is thirty-five dollars so
basically balances out and i'm also
going to sign it and i'm going to be
there and answer questions and meet
people so if you're in the Toronto area
where you want to come to Toronto to
meet and talk april eighth from 1 to 3
p.m. eastern you can sign up at trial
dental saucier and hopefully i'll see
you there so see how these first two
events go we'll see how the turnout is
how their
action is how much fun it is chatting
with you guys and potentially expand the
tour beyond that if we feel like it's a
good fit so let me know what you think
hopefully I'll see you at one of those
two advice and now I want to get to some
of the questions from last week's video
first up is Eric this was great insight
to write in a book glad you enjoyed it
last week I did a video of the ten
lessons that I learned things that
they'd write things I did wrong things i
want to remind myself of the next time i
go through this process again if i do it
again and yeah the whole book series has
been a fun journey of doctrine to
ensuring with you guys and anybody who's
trying to write a book or wants to write
a book hopefully the headaches that I
went through and then the winds that I
went through documented on that series
are beneficial to you that's why I made
it and it was a fun series to to put
together a leaky on the cover isn't bad
I like the second line with the arrow
pointing to the highlighted word yeah so
I mentioned last week that I one of the
things that I regretted was not having
more time to do the cover I'm not expand
as this cover actually in the first
design the arrow wasn't there it was
just your one word and we added this is
the only change that I made that it was
allowed to make basically in like the
time frame that we had so the arrow is
different words you can see it there the
arrows different words and so I'm glad
you like that that was our only change
and it's okay it's okay it's a good
cover it's not terrible i'm just not a
fan of it i would have done something
different but there's a good lesson
learned it was still worth publishing
the both the book its help is amazing
and yeah come to live with the cover
next up oh PS endless does it have to be
three words for the Credo or canopy
three statements the idea with the credo
is that it represents three ideas you
have your one word whether it's believed
whether its family whether it's
extraordinary whether it's belong
whatever it is you have your one word
and then the Credo help you add more
definition to it for yourself and also
for other people looking at it whether
they're your customers or suppliers or
employees or partner is your investors
so they have a little better
understanding of what it means and so
the Credo represents three different
concepts it could be three different
words it could be three different
statements as I wanted
I want you to make sure that they're
easy to remember they're not like these
long sentences because what happens is
always a tendency to make it longer and
longer and longer and longer and then
you'll remember it I want these three
things to be memorable so that if
somebody asks you what you created was
you don't have to open your notebook and
find it you know it and so that's the
danger that's the risk if you make them
long statements that you not going to
remember them if you don't remember them
low at the point the whole point is that
it's easy to remember said you can start
to live by it and other people can know
you buy it and they can know how to help
you know how to interact with you know
if we want to buy from you or not that's
the hesitation doesn't have to be three
different words but I would really
strongly recommend that you shrink it
down next up non-stop how you have
another of your videos can you make a
video about how to spend your money best
in your company so at the start I'm not
a big fan of spending any money I like
to build stuff up using my energy in my
heart my time my effort and not spending
money until I make you money and so it's
thinking where do i send my time to get
some dollars coming in I have this big
vision for I want to take something
right you have this big vision for you
want to take something and you're
starting here at the bottom and it's
okay like a lot of you want to take
these giant steps but if you try to take
a giant step you're going to make a lot
of mistakes and so if you take out a
mortgage on your house to take this big
giant step in it doesn't work you might
be in debt for the rest your life now
because of this extra load that you took
out and I don't want that for you I want
you to prove to yourself that's worth
spending your time we're spending more
dollars in it and so at the beginning
i'm spending zero dollars where should
you spend your money nowhere keep it in
your bag you can keep putting your
investment if you get to the point where
you're making money once you start
making money you're investing a lot of
it back into your business and from
there i'm looking at what is going to
give me the highest return to my dollars
just like you want to be thinking what's
giving me the highest return on my time
any resource you have this is what being
an entrepreneur is all about any
resource you have is going to be limited
you have limited funds you have limited
team may be 0 right now you have limited
time everything is limited if what do
you do with that limited resource what
do you do with your money what do you do
with your time going to do with the
connection that you have the friend of
the family maybe people in your team
volunteer
is whatever it is how do you best use
all of those resources what's going to
generate the biggest result for the
least amount of input and so when you
pour dollars on something you want to be
gasoline right so it's like hey I've
started this marketing campaign it's
working now if I put some money into it
it's going to work even more right and
you're testing and your chest and your
testing you see what's working you find
something and I like to go all in on
that dominated crush it explode it
that's where I want to focus manage you
because it's working first I'm making
sure that I'm making some kind of money
on it and then two I'm looking at okay
how do I find the thing that if I put a
dollar and I'm getting five out so it
could be a lot of different activities
it speaks to where your strengths are
what your market is there's no like one
answer that put all your money into
instagram has rights that may be a great
strategy or may not if you don't know
what you're doing so that's my advice
good luck next up the howling Chihuahua
I love that me your one word is a badass
book because it inspired me to be
fearless in my entrepreneur journey
thinks he's seeing his people i love
that that that's why i wrote the book
you know i had tremendous success using
these strategies and I was having
success with the people around me
adopting those strategies and I wanted
to share with you guys I want to share
with entrepreneurs I struggled so much
in getting my first business off the
ground and the reason why do all of this
is I wanted to make your journey a
little bit easier I'm kind of thinking
back to myself trying to help the 19
year old Evan who is starting his first
business and sucking and failing in you
know down and feeling worthless because
if nothing was working out and
everything I do is kind of thinking back
to that entrepreneur trying to help him
not quick cuz I I did quit and I came
back thankfully but I wanted to make the
road a little bit easier for other
entrepreneurs who are going through it
in all the content that I make that's
the purpose and when I discovered a
strategist that became the book like I
need to share this I need to get it out
there people need to see this stuff they
need to apply it and so it's awesome
what did you say you're fearless in your
entrepreneur journey I love it I love
seeing the success stories coming in
thank you for leaving a comment it
really really means a lot to me knowing
that you guys are picking up copies and
seen the benefit there's another comment
from the halloween Chihuahua I love your
summer
in hashtag beautiful I don't actually
have a submarine I just move my ring
around when I'm thinking I play with my
ring I like the motion so usually it's
it's on one of my two what are these
fingers ring fingers I guess rain where
the ringers but also when I'm thinking
or speaking about a pop it on the thumb
is that it obviously does not fit on the
thumb right it doesn't fit there but
lets me funny and then he also wrote if
you ever come as a Fresno area I hope
you give me five minutes of your time to
get an autograph on your badass book
after a 10 year seminar all
entrepreneurs need to get this year one
would look to step up their entrepreneur
game thank you for being awesome well
I'm not coming to fresno when i'm coming
to LA I don't know how big the drive
that is for you but get working on it
hopefully I'll see you soon next up
Sharif I've done decades of graphic
design or related work I don't think
you're looking at your cover objectively
Evan you should be happy as it is an
excellent modern yet simple informa be a
clear original yet professional
different yet minimalist it's easily an
above-average book cover any simpler and
it would look less greeting anymore
design and they would have looked too
busy so there's a lot of people like to
book cover my agent loves the book cover
my publisher loads the book cover I'm
sure the people in the art department of
the book cover aren't coming up from two
perspectives you know one when you say
it's easily an above-average book cover
that doesn't get me excited I don't want
to be an above-average anything like the
things that I'm spending a year of my
time creating I don't want it to just be
above average like that that upsets me
deeply that the work that I'm spending
so much time on because the content in
the book is not just above average it's
way better than above average and so I'm
upset that the cover that reflects it is
just above average and the second part
is you know a lot of this is what comes
from the heart you know when you look at
something art is subjective so I look at
that and I'm just not moved by it you
know I want to be moved by it you may be
moved by it you may like it a lot of
people like it but you know ideally I
want to look at something and say man
look at that cover and every time I look
at it I remember
I believe I remember the impactor I'm
just I'm loud by and it just doesn't do
it you know like these pictures behind
me are here for a reason the selection
the angle the basis that everything the
size is all designed and picked with
with importance with relevance there's a
reason why they're all here those reason
why there's five and reason why they
look in certain ways you know this
there's a reason for all of them I got
to do that i'm happy i love walking in
here every day right you know I just
don't love it that's all I love that you
guys love it I just don't love it that's
okay I'm not complaining next time it's
a good lesson to me that I got to do
better I've got to plan it out more I
guess I'm just as much time on the
outside as a date on the inside last
stop Eden Clayton biggest influencers of
2016 Eric Thomas Tai Lopez Gary be Tony
Robbins and Evan Carmichael keep going
my god wow thank you for the love of
Aden you know it's an honor to be
included in that group i'm glad i'm
having an impact on your life and
hopefully using a content to do great
things in your business and spreading
the message to others to help influence
them as well so thank you guys for the
love i'm looking forward to meeting you
hopefully today in LA it's not april
eight in toronto and if not leave your
questions down below and I will answer
them in next week's episode thank you
guys to joining me I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love I'll see you soon